what temperature is the inside of a
tauntaun lukewarm the Battle of Hoth a
huge loss for the rebels but a huge win
for bad jokes is recreated in star wars
battlefront Walker assault mode but
after complaints of imbalance and bias
towards the Imperials what a dice doing
to resolve the issue I'm Kate and this
is your gamespot news update dice has
acknowledged that star wars battlefront
Walker assault mode is not very well
balanced favouring the Imperial side
over the rebels and a sledge to address
this for the final game writing on
Twitter one fan claimed he never won a
war assault match as the rebel side
during the beta he asked does this mean
I'm suck dice community manager Matthew
Everett replied nope it's a balancing
issue within the beta lead multiplayer
designer Dennis brownville added yeah
it's too tough we'll make changes based
on the feedback and data asymmetric
modes are tricky and risky but
potentially awesome that's why we want
beta test help in the 40 player Walker
assault mode the rebel side tries to
destroy to Empire 80 80 s by securing
outposts to call in y-wing bombers
Empire forces meanwhile try to keep the
rebels from activating the command post
it would appear the rebels have the
tougher job dice is not yet said how
specifically it will change Walker
assault to make it more fair and
balanced the battle from release date is
locked in for november seventeenth about
a month before JJ Abrams Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens hits
theaters dice is developing tie n DLC
that will be free for all battlefront
players but people who pre-order will
get to play before everyone else did you
think Walker assault was unfair or did
you manage to win as the Rebel Alliance
let us know in the comments below I'm
Kate you can follow me on Twitter at how
not to draw and make sure to keep it
gamespot com for all your latest news